uh welcome David and Welcome to our
audiences on Twitter uh YouTube and
wsj.com
um David uh let's start with one of the
big questions hanging over the economy
and markets which is uh are we in a new
world of higher interest rates and
higher inflation or as some of the
markets are beginning to price in are we
going to see quite a rapid reversal
towards what we've seen over over recent
years coming into next year well first
thank you for having me and I'm
delighted to uh delighted to be here
with everybody
um we're definitely in an environment of
higher rates
not surprising you and I were talking a
little bit backstage not surprising that
after a very very extended period of
very easy monetary conditions
we had a couple of very very significant
events endemic which really shut the
world down for a period of time
disrupted Supply chains in a very tear
your way and then very very meaningful
fiscal stimulus
another Black Swan event in the context
of the war it's not surprising that
that's led to inflation really embedded
um you know in our economic system
pretty consistently
and we're now in the process of trying
to unwind that or bring that down or get
it back down toward a Target because
inflation is such a punitive tax on
economic activity and you know naturally
you're seeing monetary policy shift
relatively quickly and so we're in a
period of higher rates now the market is
telling you if you look at for example
the treasury curve it's inverted and so
the Market's making an assumption that
will reach you know kind of the terminal
rate here sometime soon and the forward
will bring rates back down and certainly
if you look at most
in Cycles historically after some period
of time you do see a reversal but I
think we're still early in this I think
it's uncertain and we still have a
pretty strong economy and particularly
if you look at service Industries and
you look at how tight labor is at the
moment I think we still have a ways to
go to get to the right balance but we'll
have to watch it it's uncertain and I
don't anybody who tells you they know
they don't know but are you are you sure
are you concerned that markets have got
ahead of themselves here on on the
hoping for this slightly Goldilocks
outcome well it's it's not it's not a
question of markets getting ahead of
themselves one of the things I've
learned over my nearly 40 Years of doing
this is markets are pretty smart but
that doesn't always mean that at any
moment in time that they're 100 right
our economists uh certainly look for
slower growth next year they're calling
for 1.9 growth globally
um but they are of the view that there's
a reasonable chance of having a
relatively soft landing and I would
Define a soft Landing as we get
inflation back to close to four weeks
four percent inflation maybe we have a
five percent terminal rate we have one
percent growth you know that's a
scenario
um I think there's a reasonable
possibility we could navigate a scenario
like that but I also think there's a um
you know a very very reasonable
possibility that we could have a
recession
um of some kind and I think at this
point when I talk to most CEOs when I'm
not talking to clients most CEOs are
cautious about how they're operating
their business they're looking through
the lens and saying hey I don't know you
know certainly we're tiny tightening
economic conditions I'd rather prepare
for that more difficult environment and
be a little bit more cautious right now
and of course that you know that creates
that you know negative cycle because
people slow down their planning they
hold back on some spending they start
trimming you know labor they want that
they want to be a little bit a little
bit tighter so they've got more
protective room if it is a more
difficult scenario so you talk about
trimming I mean how much you
bring in anticipation of this well we're
we we are obviously very focused and um
correlated to the economic environment
you think about Goldman Sachs our
business is very correlated to growth in
the world and Global activity and so it
wouldn't surprise you that in an
environment where it's slowed down very
very quickly it has an impact on our
business and coming off an extraordinary
period we had record Revenue record
earnings in 2020 2021 then again at an
even higher level it wouldn't surprise
you that the footprint you know grows
and most businesses are seeing this it's
a natural phenomenon that you therefore
have to trim you know in some areas and
pull back and so we're going through the
process of thinking about you know how
we're going to do that but for sure you
know we'll have to narrow our footprint
a little bit and as you've signaled this
you've been trying to get people back
into the office for a while has this
encouraged people to come back in a way
that maybe they weren't before I you
know I just say that it's you know every
business has to do what what it thinks
is right for their business this you
know I have not had a strong point of
view about how others should run their
business but I have a very strong point
of view about how much should run its
business and our business is is a
Professional Services human capital
business where 50 of the people who work
for Goldman Sachs around the world are
in their 20s and they come to Goldman
Sachs to have an experience to learn to
work in teams to collaborate and if if
that's all fragmented that experience
breaks down and that's a hugely
important part of what Goldman Sachs is
how we serve our clients how we operate
and so we needed to create a culture of
bringing people back very quickly
because we thought it was hurting our
competitive position as a business and
so we have nudged cajoled evolved but
the bottom line is we generally are
operating you know pretty close to the
way we operated before the pandemic
certainly Monday to Thursday we're
operating pretty close to the way we're
operating before the pandemic Friday's a
little different and I also highlight
it's a U.S issue we have a big Global
footprint we operate in 45 to 50
countries around the world the
discussion is not occurring in other
countries the way it's it's been
occurring here so they were coming back
before they were coming back before okay
that's that's the way we want to operate
our business and I think most CEOs are
are basically finding ways to send out
messages and make choices that are
appropriate for their business okay one
of the other big changes in the world
over the last year or so has been
um obviously the Ukraine war this this
kind of sudden cutting off of energy
Supply to Europe we've had a lot of
tension with China people trying to
reassure their production and and
diversify away from that Reliance on on
China how do you see the outlook for
globalization are we in a
deglobalization period and what does
that mean
well the the the term you use I don't
like the term deglobalization I I I
would I I would come at this from a
perspective that there are a variety of
global forces that have been placed for
a long time
um that are expanding and connecting
economic activity around the world uh
certainly as a as a world we've brought
a lot of people out of poverty around
the world I think you know one of the
issues with inflation and what's going
on right now is you might have a
reversal on parts of the developing
World especially if you think about
energy prices and things like that but
generally speaking uh we're relatively
economically intertwined you know
globally
and in a more complex geopolitical
environment you start to see people
making slightly different decisions so
I'd say the way I'd frame it is over the
last few decades we've really operated
with an ethos all over the world of make
it in the place where it's as
inexpensive as possible and sell it in
the place where you can accomplish the
higher margin and now people are
rethinking with certain things with with
energy with food with minerals with
certain Health Care needs with
microchips people are saying okay I need
security I've obviously got to consider
you know cost and friction but there's
some things where actually cost and
friction don't matter what matters is
security access stability
and you know that and of itself is
inflationary and you know those that
that shift I think is a more permanent
shift but that doesn't mean we're
deglobalizing that just means that in a
global economy we're choosing much more
carefully and a little bit more
thoughtfully who our partners are on
certain things and I think that's only
getting Amplified because at the moment
the geopolitical world's gotten a little
bit more complex so you have a business
in China what is your sense given the
current situation when you think about
deploying more capital in China well as
a U.S company who does business in China
and a lot of our our business in China
is dealing with global companies who are
operating in China it's not as though
we're manufacturing something and in um
in China uh We've we've we've been more
cautious you know in our plan and our
Outlook and you know I spent a lot of
time uh down here in Washington over the
last couple of years
um you know talking to people on the
hill talking to people involved in the
intelligence community and I just I
think there's a risk of kind of a more
restrictive Capital allocation policy
coming from either side and so if you're
a capital allocator if that's one of the
things you do you probably want to have
a tighter control on your financial
resources so that you have less exposure
to that given the uncertainty that
exists around how this is going to
operate and so we um
we have a more cautious Approach at the
moment we're still present we're there
to serve our clients
um but I think until we have more
clarity as to how the policy around this
is going to evolve in the coming years
um we want to be more cautious and
candidly if we were sitting here in 2019
where the dialogue around this was
different
and we were talking about this you asked
me with China I would have said
something like
I think that the U.S relationship with
China this bilateral relationship is the
most
challenging thing we have to face when
we think about global growth for the
next decade and it's certainly something
that we think is going to be a struggle
you know over the coming years so this
is not something that we've gotten
focused on only recently this is
something we've been focused on you know
for a number of years so you're at the
moment sort of unpause but not going
fast but not going slow yeah I'd say
that one of the ways you can measure
what we do in any Market is you know
what kind of financial resources do we
have allocated we have a narrower
Financial footprint allocated in this
environment than we might have you know
three four years ago so I'm going to
take advantage of you on stage for
something that I think people would like
to hear which is given all of this given
where we sit at the moment I want to do
a very quick fire set of questions just
around certain assets and just give me a
quick kind of in a year's time is this
going to be up or down okay and I'm
really bad at this I know I'm not saying
I just want to put that out I'm not
saying you're going to be right what I
say I am not a problem I'm just curious
because you have a pretty interesting
lens on the world so U.S stocks in a
year's time uh lower uh treasury yields
uh treasury yields where on the Curve
dollar
I
slightly stronger
slightly stronger let's go back to
treasure Hills 10-year just a second
longer at 10 years opposed to giving you
a number you know if you if you listen
to my to my view
um you know we've got we've we've we've
got a yield curve that if we normalize
if you get that soft Landing you'll see
if you get that stuff Landing you'll see
10-year higher if you don't get that
soft Landing you know you're going to
see you're going to see a reversal of
policy and then you can see rates the
same or lower okay then uh soft Landing
yes no
um
can I say 35 35 35 so funny okay oil
uh higher residential real estate
lower commercial real estate
lower which is going to be worse
I correlated real estate real estate at
the end of the day I mean it's great to
to snap these things out very quickly
but real estate's a financing trade at
the show today so if interest rates are
higher real estate by definition the cap
rate's different it's it's it's got to
be lower
crypto
what about it
okay let me ask a different question
um it's I it's it's I I've said this
over and over again I I and I actually
just you know on their publication and
and op-ed just went up on the topic of
blockchain I you know I find
cryptocurrencies Bitcoin those things
that people are speculating and
completely uninteresting not really
relevant not in our mindset very very
focused on the underlying technology the
ability to innovate in financial
services to innovate with financial
infrastructure we did a bond uh just
last week for the European Investment
Bank that we settled in 90 seconds
instead of the normal three to five days
that it would take Taking latency out of
financial markets we have Capital tied
up and risk tied up I think there's
really interesting Innovation that can
come and I I would hope that as we move
forward the regulatory process will
allow the big regulated institutions
that I think of risk management
capability and Innovation capability and
Market understanding and ability to kind
of participate more broadly in this
Innovation I'd like to get into that in
a little bit more detail but just
quickly on
on crypto tokens which obviously have
been quite a big deal I mean do you
think that Bitcoin will have meaningful
value in 10 years personally do you
think that will still be a thing I don't
know you just don't know I don't know
okay honest I I you don't care I really
I don't want to say that I mean I know
if I use the you use those words I
didn't so okay you know it it can't
appear in the paper tomorrow that I said
that but it's just with all the things
with all the things um with all the
things we're focused on with all the
things we're focused on the value of
Bitcoin is sure it's not it's it's not
something that I view is really
significant speculative it's a
speculative thing that people are
speculating in it might be worth
something it it might not
um but I don't really see it having a
use case which I think is the more okay
the more interesting you know the more
interesting you have to focus on okay
and we're going to see more bankruptcies
come through post FTX I mean do you
expect this to continue to Ripple
there's there's a whole ecosystem here
um and people use the word crypto and
you can be talking about blockchain and
the technology and trying to innovate
around
um around the financial infrastructure
you could be talking about stable coins
sure
um and tokenization and honestly stable
coins are really just another form of a
bank deposit
um I think they need a rule set around
them so people you know really you know
really understand that but then you can
get into Central Bank digital currencies
and you can get into cryptocurrencies
Etc all that falls into this big basket
that um that we call crypto there's a
whole infrastructure of companies that
are trying to innovate around all of
this and they span across that whole
range a lot of the companies will be
super successful in my opinion
particularly in areas like in the you
know infrastructure innovation in terms
of the way money moves in terms of
payment rails I think there are
opportunities
um you know in Neo banks for people to
do interesting things but as you as you
move into the the infrastructure that's
basically taking cryptocurrency tokens
and lending against them and trying to
create a financing business against
those platforms obviously a lot of the
errors come out of that but that's a
place where the business models are more
uncertain more vulnerable you know
tougher for me to see how they evolve
you know with a five-year View and is
there anything in that wreckage that's
interesting for a company like you to go
in and and make better any of these
exchanges that are interesting for a
regulated business like you want to try
and develop well we're still we're still
you know in terms of cryptocurrencies
and these tokens Etc we're still from a
regulatory perspective excluded you know
from participating in a lot of this I I
do think again I'd go back to the
underlying technology and we're spending
a lot of time trying to innovate around
using blockchain technology
I talked about this this bond with the
European Investment Bank we're also
looking think about bank loans when
people buy and sell bank loans the
latency in terms of how they settle it
takes 30 60 90 120 days to settle a bank
loan we've been working on a digital
platform that's a digital loan
administrative platform that we've
recently launched that gives us an
opportunity to take the latency out of
settling bank loans that's a really
valuable that's a valuable tool so I
think there are lots of interesting
areas for large institutions like ours
to look at the technology and say how
can this technology take risk out of the
market system strengthen the market
system and that's that's where our focus
is and how much you ramping up
investment in this area and how
significant is it I we we've got people
all over the firm that are that are
spending time you know um
you know I think it's an interesting
area and we certainly have resources
devoted to it and the scope of Goldman
Sachs I would view it as interesting and
and I've you know one of you know 30 40
Focus items where we think they're
interesting opportunities significance
of big word and a big organization I
think it's an opportunity we want to be
able to advise clients we want to be
able to think about the direction of
travel and so we have some focus on it
and are you seeing an opportunity around
I mean developers is a big part of your
uh staff right now I think a third or so
as as people it's about its battle we
have about 11 000 Engineers out of you
know mid to high forty thousand okay so
a bit less but um are using an
opportunity as tech companies lay off
folks and and become slightly less
competitive in in the labor market to
pick up some some talent in these sort
of areas well the the the competition
for engineering Talent as the
competition for all Talent has been you
know extremely competitive over the last
few years
um we've we've been I think an
interesting uh you know in interesting
Talent acquirer of engineering talent
for quite some time and and candidly
we've found super talented people off
the big Tech platforms that are
interested in the puzzle of kind of the
digitization of the financial world and
the evolution of the financial world
there's been a lot of you know
Innovation and evolution around software
et cetera but banking in the financial
world has been slow because it's so
highly regulated and I actually think
now you're starting to see you know
movement and a rethinking of that and a
very very regulated industry and so
we've found some super talented super
senior Engineers out of um the big big
Tech platforms over the course the last
few years that are really intrigued with
the puzzle of how you know moving
financial data into the cloud how we
connect with our clients
um in the platform that we're in how
that's all evolving
um our our CIO is a gentleman named
Marco argenti who came from Amazon I was
very very involved in in web services
and you know he's attracted a lot of
super interesting people you know off
the tech platforms
you know is is the war for talent going
to be a little bit less competitive and
a tougher economic scenario probably is
that a good opportunity for Goldman
Sachs sure but I I think I think for
great talent in almost any economic
environment you know the world's going
to be a pretty competitive place
so we've talked a little bit about
Twitter today we're not going to do too
much on Twitter but I did have a
question or two which is you on the
right side of this deal you advised
Twitter you got a good price for Twitter
I would say uh 44 billion um you weren't
left with uh some leveraged uh debt of
certain descriptions on your balance
sheet um what do you think Twitter's
worth now I I don't I mean I I don't
have a point of view on that I don't I
don't know I don't have a point of view
I'm I'm watching I'm watching I'm
watching the movie I'm watching the
movie with all of you and you know I've
got my popcorn and my soda and you know
I'm I'm I'm I'm you know I'm settling it
I on a serious note it's a super
interesting platform yeah and
you know to be really interested to see
if Elon can kind of get it right turn it
into a business and have it work in our
society where there's trust with it and
and you know it it you know it
participates in function in a way that
that you know it's really embraced and
it's got a business model that can be
supported and sustainable but I I'm I'm
not that close to the deal and you know
I'm watching from the sidelines so what
impact has the deal had on confidence in
leveraged finance and to what extent is
the buyer Market really open right now
well the buyout Market really isn't open
right now because you haven't really had
this rebalance of the cost of capital
with the multiples that people expect
for their their um their businesses
um and so the bio Market is really you
know relatively constrained I I don't
think Twitter in itself had any real
impact on the you know on the buyout
Market I think the buyout Market
constrained very very quickly because
you had a significant repricing on
multiples and you had a significant
repricing and financing and so that
brought activity to a to a much to a
much slower level actually interesting
if you go back historically the amount
of kind of Leverage lending on large
bank balance sheets that's um you know
that's underwater is it a historically
low is that right level yeah when you
when you think about other other Cycles
where you had a pretty aggressive cycle
and then something you know stop the
cycle or revalued or remarked you know
leverage Finance broadly you know the
risk exposures are much much more
moderate at that point in the cycle when
things shut down than they've been at
other points in a similar cycle
interesting I've got two more questions
I want to just quickly
um
go out one is um
what's happened to due diligence uh
there seems to be a lot of deals done
recently where people have you know
texted I'll give you another billion
here or there obviously Elon waved due
diligence on Twitter what's changed here
why is some of this happening is it just
a
I don't I don't think anything's changed
I think due diligence is an incredibly
important part of of the process of of
almost anything you do or you're going
to invest you're going to acquire get
involved you're going to partner
um I just say as an observer of markets
over long periods of time you know we
get into periods of ambulance and
markets
um where people are riding a momentum
wave and there are a lot of people
making a lot of money on the momentum
wave and discipline and behavior you
know weekends and we've we've seen it
once we've seen it before we'll see it
again and occasionally that happens and
you know people chooted choose to do
things at a velocity or a speed or with
less with less rigor and generally when
people do that sometimes people get away
with it if they're doing it early enough
in that momentum train and
sometimes you know they catch the
Caboose and they wind up getting getting
getting getting getting left off in a
bad place but it's it's um I I don't I
don't I don't fundamentally see that
that's the way you know good
professional investors you know operate
and I don't I don't see that changing
there's no there's no change there so
final question
um we've seen a few uh moments recently
we saw in the UK the pensions explosion
or near explosion when we had this
slightly abortive budget and uh guilt
rates went through the roof we've seen
recently in commercial real estate some
challenges around liquidity blackstone's
fund has has limited some of the
withdrawals Etc when you look around
um the financial system at the moment
where do you see the the biggest risks
that we should be thinking about well I
I think there are a couple things I mean
it's a significant growth in government
debt
um you know around the world and we've
we've also seen uh whether you pointed
to the you know you pointed to UK guilds
but you know we saw it here in 2020 when
we were under a little pressure the way
the treasury market operated here you
know just Market functioning you know
around government debt and also where
there's back leverage against government
debt you know and thinking about
government debt at a time where were
governments have significantly increased
the borrowing I think that's something
to you know to watch and think about
um there's a lot of activity given the
way the regulatory structure has evolved
over the course you know the last you
know 10 15 years there's a lot of
activity that used to be in the
regulated banking system that is now
outside the regulated banking system and
there's leverage and financing against
that and you know I think this this
activity outside the regulated banking
system I think that's something to watch
something to think about are there any
particular areas within that there's a
lot of there's a lot of direct lending I
mean a lot of lending goes on you know
outside you know outside the regulated
banking system that's actually a good
thing I think you know broadens access
to Capital et cetera but you know you've
got to watch where people are using
leverage you know to drive returns and
capabilities around that and you know I
think that's something to watch and so
far in this contraction this this um
this tightening of economic conditions
we really haven't seen a material moving
credit spreads and so to the degree that
there was something that started to move
credit spreads in a material way then
I'd be looking you know I'd be looking
at lending activities you know broadly
but we haven't we haven't gotten there
at this point I don't know that we will
get there it doesn't mean we necessarily
and in terms of something like a
liquidity mismatch I mean how could How
concerned you about something like
commercial real estate where people are
in these long long-term funds and they
particularly want to get liquidity and
obviously you've got a double whammy of
rising interest rates and not people not
coming back to the office Etc I mean is
that a concern that asset costs for you
well I I um I I do think and I said it
before real estate you know sure it real
estate's valued in the context of what
it costs to finance it and so depending
if people are financed very very long in
their real estate they can withstand all
sorts of things on a cycle if your
financed short or you know you're in a
place where you haven't financed your
assets to match your tenants and your
rent flows then you're obviously much
more vulnerable to that I you know I
fundamentally think that Prime
commercial real estate and Prime cities
you know is relatively protected I think
you know
third class real estate you know in most
cities is going to have a very tough
time but it's it's having a tough time
it's gonna have a tough time not because
of this debate about whether people are
going into workspace Etc it's going to
have a tough time because the the
expectation of what you get in
world-class buildings the the continued
evolution of the way services are
provided the space is made Etc you know
continues to make you know older
buildings you know more Antiquated or
require much more Capital you know to be
competitive and you know that's a trend
that I think you know more long-dated
rooted so I've taken up most of David's
time in fact all of it but I I do want
to offer one question and we have a
gentleman in the front can we just take
one very quick question please
apologies for not giving more time on
this I'm sorry
thanks I'll be quick uh hey David Sid
Wilson CEO of the Hispanic Association
on corporate responsibility
um Goldman Sachs has been such a a
leader in in calling for diversity on
companies like you're bringing public
um can you talk about what you've been
seeing is are you seeing movement there
and are you also seeing a dialogue with
other investment Banks to uh hold that
standard the way Goldman Sachs has so um
so so I appreciate the question and as
you highlighted um a handful of years
ago I guess it would be three years ago
because it was it was January 2020. you
know we made a statement that we would
not we would not take companies public
in the U.S or in Western Europe
um unless there was diversity in their
governance
um and you know we did that because we
thought it was something that was was
very very important broadly but we also
did it because we thought it would have
an impact on the broader ecosystem at
that point in time it wasn't like there
weren't that there were lots and lots of
public companies that didn't have
diverse governance you know in place
there were some though that were going
public that didn't but the whole private
Equity Venture Capital ecosystem was not
focused on diversity and governance and
was really dealing with it as a kind of
afterthought at the moment of going
public or at the moment becoming a more
you know a bigger more visible company
and I think one of the things that's
happened is there's been a lot more
attention placed broadly on diversity
and governance you know across all
businesses whether they're private
whether they're public large small Etc I
think that's a very healthy thing I
think we played a small role in
contributing to that dialogue and
accelerating that dialogue and we've
tried to contribute also by working with
our clients to place you know clients
diverse clients
um you know onto boards both public and
private we've got a whole ecosystem
that's run by a woman named a lot of
wolf where we get very very good
feedback from clients and I think in a
boardroom having a diverse set of views
different experiences it leads to better
performance there's lots of empirical
data that shows that and so there's
still work to do on that front but I
feel like we've made a small
contribution in advance in it
great um thank you David we are out of
time but thank you very much appreciate
it thank you very much
[Applause]